please do me i know we haven't got time
to do it now but can you just stay and
do me
that sounds
like an offer
again so uh absolutely i'm always cut to
an interval just i mean i'm always
associated with being a you know a man
who has a background and education and
i'm well mannered and
you know i have to protect and protect
that image
don't you think
i think that's it's
tremendously important the image is is
terribly important too
we did put on our robes but we did it
more for a joke we didn't actually
bollock anymore i said oh oh no i'm so
sorry about that i'm so sorry oh no
that's all right i'm so sorry she's
australian i'm australian we didn't tell
anyone off oh no
i didn't finish
[Applause]
tony one two three four five being on
these things one two three four five
hours news shows so often you know
and those new shows are terrible tony
i'm telling you i just realized it
because i'm here in the news show in the
background you know you always think
that you're doing those good morning
shows but this is one of those news
shows
kim i'm telling you this is crazy i
don't want to do this
tony i'm going to be part of the local
news how exciting
tony danza
we never know when people are listening
to what you're saying tony
right after murder and mayhem and the
rescue in california tony danza i'm so
excited
okay tony can you hear me now yes i can
okay we're going to start the interview
now no murder in mayhem just the
interview about your movie you ready all
right fine oh you heard me huh oh every
bit of it oh good joining us now is tony
danza you know him from what you feel i
mean don't you feel a little bit like
that's what you do i mean i'm not for
nothing
not just me who thinks that by the way
go ahead all right you know tell me how
i make my living so you know no no
listen
i'm just saying you can't just don't
deny it you know please i don't care you
should make a living i think that's fine
okay well there's so much secrecy around
this new film what what can you tell me
about it obviously you've told me that
it's you having a drink i think it's uh
i feel like that's with us
that's where this is headed
there is a darkness and there is a
dystopian atmosphere
but there is also a triumph of the human
spirit
all right what can you add to that is
there a mic i can drop
[Laughter]
smash after smash after smash what can
you tell us about your dress this
evening katy perry well i was inspired
by priscilla presley in the 70s
i'm married to elvis presley of course
the big hair closer to god
but how did you focus during that
interview she look i've never seen her
look well you know juliana when you are
my height you have a lot of experience
staying focused at that eye line
good job thank you babe
harry belvani joining us live this
morning from new york hey good morning
harry
harry wake up
harry yeah
yes wake up wake up breathing
okay
this is your wake-up call
there's nothing okay um i'll tell you
what
we are going he's yeah he's meditating
he's having he's taking a little nap
taking a little nap see see the daylight
happens
he's okay he is okay
damn
have you ever hit anything that you've
been throwing at funnily enough i've
never willy-wanged since then
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
here are the nominees
for argo ben affleck
for zero dark 30 catherine bigelow
and for django unchained quentin
tarantino
and the golden globe goes to
[Applause]
ben affleck argo
you see we don't we don't yeah we don't
stint here are you calling me a slime
you know i wondered i wondered why they
called you a society entertainer
slice of cake
okay some cake yeah yeah thank you you
you look you look as fit as a flea
you do any special exercises for that
not really
all right i got to plug this
i just touched your boobs
roll that back i didn't see that
[Applause]
[Applause]
shields you're super hot you made me
think i was straight for like 23 years
any comments
when i'm up on stage there's zara and
you haven't watched i'm gonna try that
again five six seven eight when i'm up
on stage there are some i don't know
what i'm doing oh my god there's a lot
of so
when i'm up on stage there's lots of men
who like to watch in fact one guy sent a
twit pic of his crotch
nice it was worth it
totally improvised
recent polls have shown a fifth of
americans can't locate the u.s on a
world map
why do you think this is
i personally believe
that u.s americans are unable to do so
because
some
people out there in our nation don't
have bounce and i believe that our
education like such as south africa and
iraq everywhere like such as and
i believe that they should
our education over here in the us should
help the us
should help south africa and should help
the iraq and the asian countries so we
will be able to build up our future for
our children thank you very much south
carolina
yeah you're absolutely right about
america here's rihanna to take us
america hey oh get that on a t-shirt get
that on a t-shirt i got a chunk wheeler
now
[Music]
end up participating inside just a
minute now
he's going to do something i understand
what he's up to now and you really start
to watch what's happened that's the
other thing about the humor is you have
to pay attention to it
and hollywood is a place
that creates uh
a viewer
escape
and um what i try to do is i as a
director i try to
ah
the type is all off sorry but i'll just
wing this
tell us what you think yeah we will just
we'll wing it right now
um i take i try to take people on an
emotional ride and um
the curve
how does it uh how do you think it's
going to impact
how viewers experience your movies
excuse me i'm sorry i'm sorry
okay
ladies and gentlemen let's thank michael
bay for joining us
and for the songs that create their most
memorable moments here to perform the
oscar-nominated gorgeously empowering
song let it go from the oscar-winning
animated movie frozen please welcome the
wickedly talented one and only
tazeem
[Music]
uh of course have faith
and film on and many many other
companies good to have you here
thank you so much you look beautiful
nishka well i'm a little bit chilly john
that's okay
okay i don't want to put my mouth on
that now that's absolutely disgusting
oh my goodness
um
jennifer i'm not often speechless but i
think i've actually been caught
speechless
oh no that's it my bar just broke
i just inhaled and went knock
should have gotten the 12 million dollar
bra that's what happened can you bring
anything i can give
[Applause]
[Applause]
i got it here it is jay here oh is it
over here
marty how you making out well i'm doing
fine he's got his ass
let's make a wish